[Music]
corruption thrives during times of
crisis
the coronavirus pandemic is no exception
traders have inflated prices for scarce
supplies like masks and hand sanitizers
politicians have received kickbacks for
brokering deals
their aim
to profit from others misfortune
hello and welcome to our kobe 19 special
i'm monica jones thanks for tuning in
almost 5 million people have died of
covet 19 so far millions more have lost
their health and livelihoods and yet
there are some who have no qualms about
using this major crisis for personal
gain
dw's lis shaw reports from africa and
takes a close look at who the pandemic
was especially generous too
ppe kits
overalls like this one here
gloves masks hand sanitizers and
government financial aid are some of the
things that have helped us health-wise
and financially throughout the
coronavirus pandemic
but
some people have pocketed these medical
items or the relief money to make
themselves rich
the pandemic has encouraged corruption
and mismanagement throughout the globe
but my question today is who's profiting
from covert 19 in africa
since the outbreak of kovite 19 in
nigeria and the african countries were
working we've seen that the rich are
getting richer and the poor are getting
poorer the rich who have friends in
corridors of power who have allies are
the ones getting contracts you know to
handle logistics distribution and
procurement
take kenya for example back in august
2020 kenya was rocked by an
investigative report about so-called
covet millionaires 15 business people
and government officials are being
investigated for allegedly misusing
millions of dollars meant to buy medical
supplies
in zimbabwe health minister obadiah moyo
was fired after being involved in a
corrupt multi-million dollar deal
awarded to a foreign company to provide
anti-covet drugs and protective
equipment
in south africa a report by the
country's auditor general revealed quote
frightening findings
among other things some government
departments bought protective gear at
five times the price advised by the
treasury
in nigeria corrupt politicians even held
back food aid aimed for those who've
been hardest hit by the crisis
we saw recovery relief materials so rice
grain indomie uh were stored in the
warehouse and and the politicians were
waiting for political campaign season
they went for that to rebrand
kobe 19 relief materials and put in
their names and their pictures hamzad's
campaign managed to keep track of more
than 500 million dollars in seven
african countries to see what it was
planned for and how it is being used
it's money from donors grants or from
the government's budget still many
questions about where and how the money
is being spent often go unanswered by
those in charge
private donation was made to the fct
administration under the president
muhammadu buhari's cabinet
where this resources was meant to
provide policies provide testing kits
and also support frontline health
workers
so first we asked the minister of the
fct as a city center is he utilizing
this money and he was mutes about it so
till date we've he has not given public
knowledge or expenditure of how he has
utilized his money so why does the
pandemic open doors to corruption so
wide economists believe one reason is a
lack of checks and balances in these
extraordinary times
you know people take advantage of the
fact that the pandemic is more or less
like a security situation
so
it is easy for a public officer to say
yeah this is a security uh situation
it's an emergency situation so we need
to take decisions without recourse
to the law and that has been the problem
another thing that encourages
mismanagement of resources is the fact
that those involved often don't have to
fear legal consequences
in the case of the kenyan covet
millionaires there's criticism that the
investigations that started in august
2020 are taking way too long
why hasn't anyone been charged in court
despite
this period of time
then you kind of then get suspicious and
worry and start worrying that they could
actually be a
a process to cover up or you know or
sanitize you know someone or some people
um because they are connected to you
know
certain elites in this country
of course the temptation to turn a quick
buck is high for people close to the
corona money but let's not be too
negative here the pandemic has also
proven to be a huge business opportunity
to some they are turning profits in a
legal way
in africa smart business owners have
grabbed opportunities offered by the
pandemic sometimes in not so obvious
branches like yoga
[Music]
for example south african yoga
instructor tidi malo jasmine selako
decided to move her lessons online after
a countrywide lockdown made classes
impossible since then the number of her
followers has skyrocketed
these days i find that most of the
things that i do are online
and i could say that it really has
given me space
to become more innovative
and it's really pushed me to grow and
see
how i can strategically grow as a
creative as a brand and just
keep myself grounded as well
services that had to shift online have
given a boost to telecommunication
companies people are spending more data
to stay in touch with friends and family
and to get the latest on covet
developments also when many schools and
colleges closed e-learning forced people
to invest in data packages for their
education
we're still in the middle of the covet
19 pandemic just as it is with any
crisis of this scale there are winners
and losers the question remains how many
of those winning financially in africa
are actually playing fair
and just for the record africa isn't
alone when it comes to exploiting the
coronavirus crisis for personal gain
we've had cases of nepotism and lobbying
scandals here in europe too so what role
does governance play in a pandemic time
for one of your questions now over to
derek
how has the pandemic affected the vision
of what it means to have proper
political leadership
could politics and science be closer
partners in the future
these aren't really science questions
and trying to answer them on on my part
is going to require lots of speculation
but i think they're important questions
to be asking and so
here goes first one first a tough nut
what constitutes good political
leadership in this kind of crisis
well that depends on who you ask of
course but maybe we can all agree on a
few fundamentals the first of which i
think
is clear communication a real
biggie
trust
is a very hard thing to build and i
think in countries where leaders have
tried to communicate clearly
what measures needed to be taken to
fight the pandemic and why
people have been more likely to trust
them and and to follow the rules and to
build trust
those kinds of decisions have to be
based on an explainable framework so
they can't just be someone's opinion but
they have to reflect
the best scientific evidence that we
have at a given moment
now the best evidence we have evolves of
course as more research comes in and new
research
can always overturn earlier research
that's happened lots of times as we've
groped our way forwards
into the darkness that that is this
pandemic but all those science-based
decisions won't all be perfect and and
will require updating
all the time
science still provides the brightest
torch
that we have in that darkness and future
political leaders
who understand that will i think be
better at building trust and that brings
me to question two about whether i think
the pandemic will foster closer bonds
between science and politics in the
future and i think that unquestionably
it will because
as a friend put it to me recently
science is currently saving the world um
now lots of people might say that that's
over dramatizing but i happen to think
that it's pretty on target
without the research that led to
understanding what measures
work best to control the spread of covet
19 or or how it can best be treated
and of course the lightning fast
development of vaccines against it
the virus would unquestionably be
killing and and crippling
many many more of us and though i don't
want to leave you with a downer
this pandemic is just one of the major
major challenges that we are going to
face as a species and really the pretty
near future
for me
science provides the best chances that
we're going to have
for addressing
and hopefully mitigating those
challenges so i think it'll have to play
a much more prominent role
in politics in the future as well
before we go here's a look at some of
the other kobe 19 stories making news
around the world
people are protesting in new york
against a kobit 19 vaccination
requirement for staff in the city's
public school system the mandate went
into force on monday some demonstrators
pulled down a kobit testing tent during
the protest
the pandemic has cost the global airline
industry nearly 200 billion dollars
according to the international air
transport association that figure is
much higher than was previously forecast
ayata says carriers that rely on
long-haul flights suffered more than
their regional peers which have started
to recover
and that's all for this edition of kobe
19 special thanks for watching
[Music]
you